please just tell me how to write you
know just please tell me what i did
here's a formula you do this you do that
how does a character drive plot
it's about what they want
and what they need
and their conflicts and their flaws
um
you know it's one of the first things
most actors will look at and then when
they're
judging a script they want to play this
role
is butts characters flaw
you know what's the problem with this
character that they have to overcome or
that drives them or
so
drama i think is all about what what
does the
character want
um
and what are they willing to do to get
it
what can they do to get it
you know where the stakes gonna be
and then it just just builds hopefully
from there you know there's always that
great debate about what's what comes
first plot or character
and i've always found
in my work uh there's no rule sometimes
like i'll get an idea for a plot
um that will kind of like something i'll
read in the newspaper or something i'll
see i'm like oh wow wouldn't that be
interesting
and then i gotta figure out how to
populate it with people
uh and and
how can i invest this person with
a need
and a flaw
and an opportunity and now put them in
that plot
and then there's other times where i
just i come up with a character where it
just knows man that is a funny person
i'd love to see that person and so then
it's about how to build it around around
them so either one can come first but
ultimately it's you know what the
characters want i think
why do you think so many writers
bicker about uh plot versus character
well i think it might be because we're
all looking for formula
you know we'd all love a template
please just tell me how to write you
know just please tell me what i did
here's a formula you do this you do that
that's why i think so many of these
screenwriting books are so successful
because they sort of promise
you know okay you've got the idea that's
great but now i'm going to show you how
to apply that idea and make it work and
not that there aren't great i've read
them all and
not that there aren't great things to
learn from those books
but ultimately uh
um
you know you just have to be careful
to not rely on something outside
yourself to come up with a plot you know
her story and a friend of mine
once he wanted to be a writer so badly
and he wasn't very good and i was
recommending books for him to read
and he read a bunch of them and i said
to them so
you know did it help was it helpful he
said well not really
i mean there's a lot of stuff about you
know how to write but there was nothing
about what to write
so i said man
if you don't have anything to write
about you're not in the right business
you just gotta
do something else
yeah that's that's the real problem is
you have too much to write about there's
too many types yeah right right right do
you ever find yourself being too
precious with your characters where you
don't want to give them certain flaws or
that's never been an issue it's almost
the opposite you know i sometimes find
myself
hobbling them you know with too many too
much darkness too much stuff they're
fighting
and uh you know get feedback and saying
well you know
it's hard to root for this person
because they're a little too dark
so often i have to kind of pull back on
that sometimes and give them a little
more light
than heaviness
sure well just off camera we were
talking about uh white irish drinkers
and that's from 2010 yes okay and so uh
and i felt all of the characters
were had some flaws maybe some more than
others but i i felt that each one i
could see
maybe where they were coming from i
didn't see one that was even even the
one unlikable you could say i won't give
it away but you could see where his
character
might be coming from right and cut him
some slack yeah um and and yeah so so i
enjoyed that because even the one that
was supposedly the the squeaky clean one
there were a few flaws nothing too bad
but where everybody had their own things
they were struggling with it was a
beautiful job well thank you yeah it's
great to hear that and
i think that um you know one of the most
important things to keep in mind from a
writing point of view and also from an
acting point of view
is that even like the worst villain
in life doesn't think they're a villain
you know everyone thinks what they're
doing is the right thing even if it's
just for them
so
you know people don't go man i'm really
bad and
i'm going to do this now because i'm a
bad person
they're they're thinking that uh i'm i'm
uh misunderstood
uh i'm uh i'm hated no one likes me uh i
never got the breaks and i've got the ch
you know whatever it is that leads then
they say i deserve to rob this bank it's
not i'm a bad person i i just do
and so that's i think an important thing
with characters that's why it's fun for
me
to write villains
um because i love them i love them and i
want them to have full lives and
and uh i don't think i don't expect the
audience to like them but i want them
to understand them
and to feel and to recognize them that's
the most important thing yeah i i've
seen that person i know that person you
know when all the family first premiered
which for many of your viewers would
probably be
too young to remember that but
it was the first time on television
there was that kind of
overtly prejudiced bigoted working-class
character
you know the switchboard the cbs lit up
because they say hey my dad's on tv
that's my uncle that's my you know and
so there's nothing more magical i think
than hitting that button with an
audience of like oh
he's a
there's a specific character but there's
a universal thing that i recognize and
feel with that character and it was so
great to have the rob reiner character
butt up against archie bunker and and
two polar opposites and both very
very strong in their opinion right it
was right it was excellent yeah and the
longer you got to know archie bunker you
know because at first you hated him like
this guy's despicable
but the more you got to know him the
more you start to understand
the more they led you into his past
and how he was brought up and his
situ his experiences as a kid and the
disadvantages he had and
and you start to understand what formed
his world view
so even though you can't agree with it
you say yeah i understand how a guy like
that comes to this place where he hates
people who are different he can't stamp
you there he's frightened by people who
are different
and that's a huge step towards making
people understand each other
how do you develop a character flaw
well again
i look within you know start inside
one of the things i hate about myself
that i would like to change
i like to think that sometimes by
writing about it i can even maybe fix it
you know it just hasn't happened yet
so i mean that's the basic thing and i
always think that any time you pull from
yourself
not in an egotistical way but just in an
honest way
um you're halfway there in making a real
character
and then it's just about trying to
figure out how does this flaw
uh how how has it affected this
character growing up
um what's it made other people think of
him how has it made other people treat
him
uh does this flaw become worse because
of the way people
have treated these characters it is
self-perpetuating so you can kind of go
off on a whole bunch of
uh your tangents i try to start simply
and specifically
about
uh you know the flaw that's gonna help
me serve this plot
and and drive it forward and make for
interesting twists and turns
uh and it's another thing just
not to go away from that subject but
specificity also is i think one of the
most important things
in writing and
so often it's missing i think you know
people
beginning writers or writers who just
don't work that hard
will describe things in vague ways or
talk about emotions in general
vague ways
you know um
i miss my wife so much
uh you know she died two years ago i
miss her so much you know this is sort
of the simple example as opposed to
saying you know
when my wife came down in the morning
the first thing she did was
uh you know
put this put the cup upside down on the
you know something specific that you
really feel like
you're you can almost see and hear and
smell
uh and so that also plays into flaws and
just something that's you can exhibit uh
the character can
because characters also of course all
about behavior uh and especially in
films you know in novels you have the
luxury of having this inner life that
you can use words to describe but in
movies and tv we're just limited by what
we can see you've got to just deal with
what people are seeing so you really
have to uh
explore and illustrate behavior
it comes out character through their
behavior what we're seeing them do how
they treat each other um what they do
when they're alone
you know are they different when they're
alone and when they're with somebody
else
um how are they different with two
different people
you know this is all little tricks you
can use behaviorally to really set up
who your character is and make them
recognizable
and in your character's arcs do they
always
let's say a dark character does it
always turn themselves around or no
there's just some sort of resolve but
they're still the same
you know i think that
the best drama you the characters all
make a journey of some kind
i don't always feel like
you have to do the network television
version of it where you know the bad guy
has to see the evil of his way
you know it's it's not i mean people
um
you know a great example is i think is
uh uh there's three billboards
you know the character sam rockwell
played was just a brilliant actor
you know that's a guy who makes a
fantastic arc
and he starts off as this hateful racist
and in his relationship and dealings
with francis mcdormand
he starts to come around a little bit
and he ends up helping her but by the
end of the movie
you don't feel like this guy is going to
go out now
and go on a march
but he has regained a little bit of
humanity so you have some hope for him
and so to me that's a perfect and an
expertly done
uh character arc
uh for someone like that where you know
if he suddenly became this
touchy-feely lovey guy oh you wouldn't
believe it and wouldn't honor
the work that was done in setting up who
this guy is
so you know people i don't think
sadly you know i think people don't tend
to change very much i think they change
increments
and so you don't have to necessarily
reflect that in drama because you want
to give people something a little higher
to aspire to
but i think you have to any evolution of
a character has to be true ultimately to
who they really are
and
and
you know how they're going to manifest
that change
and in francis mcdormand's character in
in three billboards out of ebbing's
montana how does she change
well i you know i certainly think that
she becomes less
angry
uh you know i think that when
particularly sam rockwell helps her
and and she starts to feel she's not
alone
i think she finds a way to deal with her
pain
and you get the sense by the end of the
movie that okay she's probably going to
be all right she's probably she's going
to learn how to live with this pain
it's always going to be there but it's
not going to just
keep her stalled and i think at the
beginning of the movie she is just
stalled she can't go forward and so
she's not going to be this
happy-go-lucky person but you do feel
like
you know she has now maybe found another
color
in her life